users want both beauty and utility from
their watch faces they want bite-sized
information combined with the style they
love if you have an app adding a
complication data provider offers a
simple way to engage with the users on
where RS success means you now own a
piece of the screen real estate that the
user wears all day my name is Robin and
I will walk you through the concept and
development steps behind a complication
data provider one of the core UI
features of where RS by Google is the
watch face users can choose from those
shipped to their device or from
third-party developers this provides
style but what about utility and user
research we found that users like to
access bite size information from their
watch face this can range from the date
to the current temperature we call these
complications a term used by traditional
watch making one way this can be done is
for each watch face to make their own
business stills and bespoke integration
with all the app data sources that the
user can possibly want clearly this is
not a scalable solution as a result we
created the complications API to connect
watch faces with all the app data
sources on the watch there's no need for
business and data format agreements they
all pass the data according to an agreed
format with the complications API the
user can choose the watch face that
expresses their style and the data the
find the most useful if you have a
mobile application think about what is
the one piece of data the user would
most like to know and focus on that the
next step is to see how that data can be
expressed in the different types with
where OS we provide a large variety of
choices from short text to large image
try to support as many types as you
reasonably can this will ensure the
widest support from watch faces now that
you have decided what data items to show
and how they should be expressed it's
time to code to get started you can
follow the step by step code lab listed
here and I will highlight some of the
key components in this code lab at its
core a complication data provider is a
service that extends complication
providers service once the user has
selected your complication data source
where OS will bind to the service and
request data when it is needed there are
three methods I would like to highlight
first the on complication update method
this is called every time the system
requests complication data since the
same data provider can supply multiple
data types pay particular attention to
which type of data is requested before
returning the second and third methods
are repair on complication activated and
on complication deactivated
these methods are optional ending
usually not used they are called when a
watch face starts or stops displaying
data from your complication if there is
data being stored for a particular
instance of a complication it can be set
up in activated and cleared and
deactivated in addition to the
complication provider service to
metadata tags in the Android manifest
are worth highlighting the first tells
the system which complication data types
your provider supports the second tells
the system how often the complication
should be refreshed two things to note
here first although the attribute is
called update period seconds think of
this period in minutes and the longer
the better this is the battery
conservation second if your service
receives updates via push you can set
the update to trigger at irregular
periods by setting this attribute to
zero and instead trigger updates using
provider update requester you can find
full details of how this is done
in the code lab if you are a mobile app
developer creating a complication data
provider is one of the simplest and
meaningful ways you can support your
users on where OS give it a try for more
details check out the code lab mentioned
[Music]